all right ladies and gentlemen give it
up for seldom a MC Gambas I'm a boy yo
these women gotta build a boy yes so
fill me back two minutes avoid cameras
mom
[Music]
better Padma so he kill as last room
bita bit times I care was my own beats
at then I Civic it was my fault meet
Zara son sighs slow me down
[Music]
[Music]
hey buzz me [ __ ] buzz me [ __ ] boss we
should better boss Boston abortion but
neither body day
[Music]
polish accosted Armenia shazamicon
ladyship and the vanishing lucky to have
a man for you
I can just benami off for movies and UPS
an anthem like your Baba major Sahib and
a Bashar avanza pasanda shamshir uh oh
yeah uncle Oh pish-posh it'll send them
to the Kazakh oceans and Danny Caine
hakuna comes out the cross the pitiable
oh that on Sodom tell us very far
tamesha Padilla gonna spar busyness ooh
yeah for [ __ ] better toss better take
you home
Allah yes the last
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much for listening
I'm come and see and that son was he on
or fantasm from my latest album now for
sugar or excerpts from unhappy
consciousness the English things I have
another song coming out but before that
I also have a short animation that I
made a couple years ago so was enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
okay I want you to try and sing the next
line okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'd side my scarf that way and I was a
rock girl yeah so this goes back so my
father the journalist he's right now but
at the time when I was a my early teen
years eleven twelve everywhere living
goes out by John but could it was a
journalist for now I feel familiar with
it but it's official news agency in Iran
and there and our families Turk oh sorry
so however I was watching a lot of
Turkish TV I think back then a lot of
varying instead there was this Turkish
hip-hop group called cartel they're all
them came out in 95 that was the first
tip-up I was ever exposed to they had a
video music video out it's constantly
showing on Turkish show music channels
and I loved it and this this was a
German group that lived in Turkish group
that they were living in German Turkish
Despero and their music really spoke to
me I think part of it was because I was
living in Azerbaijan I was small dough
but somehow I connected and following up
on that I just kept listening to hip-hop
American hip-hop which you know I tried
to find it was mostly conscious hip-hop
so I never really listened to mainstream
American hip-hop but really good hip-hop
and I was lucky that I was given that
kind of things kind of just yeah and
eventually I was writing my own stuff
very first piece that you wrote yeah but
let's not talk about it I don't want to
remember though you know first 50 some
things that I wrote but how if we want
to talk about how I actually couldn't
sung that goes back to so I had this
blog about hip hop and it's funny I kind
of thought up talking about this when I
think was dr. Shay that talked about
Quran if music many of you know reading
it it's soaked and this was some things
that I was reading my blog and I'm like
sixteen but I was like Quran is actually
rap if I rhymes you can actually rhyme
it like I was making arguments like that
and my blog and I was really serious
about it
and back then also there was this
website called Orca which was for social
it was a you know before Facebook and a
lot of Iranians tongue got in there
and we had this hip-hop Iranian hip-hop
enthusiasts kind of hanging out and
talking about a rap yeah that's nice
well he was very mad actually how it
happened is how I met him wasn't from
Orkut necessarily but there was a swept
cycles her sake music calm which was the
only website that had hip-hop music on
it hitch castle songs were in there and
I was listening to them and I sent the
email there I said I had this blog you
know I Robot a pop if you put the link
in there will be great and they got back
to me and it was each gossip and I
didn't know that he ran the website but
he's like oh hey let's meet up
let me talk to a little bit and at first
he didn't even know I was a girl so he
was shocked and he actually found that
and he used this and that like I wasn't
really in the like Iranian straight
culture back then I was pretty sheltered
I can say so like with them hanging out
with them I was exposed but I remember
very specifically that when he first
found out that I was a girl he said
and as and I didn't and that was like
like one thing I learned from those guys
about all these you know these strict
terms and that was one of those but and
you know I was so innocent that they
would say certain things that I wouldn't
know they're real like the literal
meaning because they would use them as
you know phrases so I don't know if I
can use certain verse here but I
wouldn't know so I would go back and use
them you know with my father and you
would be like don't say that again do
you even know what you're saying I'm
like I was proud I was proud I'm I was
part of all my songs when I first made
them and then I was not proud of them
for after a few weeks but I think that
kind of in satisfaction make makes you
want to continue doing it and over the
years I talked to a lot of artists and
everyone has it so I'm good cuz I
thought I was you know crazy but
apparently that's normal yeah so the
first song that I was actually actually
proud of because my first time the first
time I ever recorded was with each cast
so you'll probably know that we made a
collaboration together and I tried a lot
to make that song disappear from the
internet but unfortunately those days
are long gone so it's still out there
but the first time that I was really
proud it wasn't a song that I made by
myself because I after working with each
gasps it was really clear to me that I
want to be independent because those
guys they're really nice they could get
a little bit controlling and I really
wanted to be my own self so I what I was
kind of separated myself from that made
the the main wave that was happening
back then and when my own way
I would just download beats made like
free beats that were made by American
producers and rap on them and my first
song - already like that I'm really
proud of because I'm completely made by
myself without you know the recording
and everything I didn't need any
guidance and I was really happy with it
you put it together in your bedroom so
well no so that was the I didn't have no
this is way before that before I had my
own studio this is still I was still
going to studios there the government
character hasn't happened yet so we
could go to studios there was this
studio called Carragher than you
probably heard of it in places that a
lot of underground music was recorded
and actually the carbon Amazon's led
there who was the sound engineer and
there I it was also my own teacher
because I was learning singing too with
them so I've believed a KAG it in a lot
and recorded that song there and you
know it done because you are going to
studios and you're gonna pay for hourly
so we would practice a lot before going
that makes sure that we can you know
record it in one take and maybe do all
the corrections afterwards so different
times because now I have a hosted yeah I
don't never memorize my lyrics got lazy
I want to know a little bit about since
we've been talking about sort of you
know women musicians inside know a
little bit about know a little bit about
would have meant to be you know a young
girl making you know getting into a
hip-hop music back then and you know so
you said in your encounter with each
cast of his troupe you sort of realized
sort of where you stood and that became
clear to you and you wanted to do your
things independently but was it actually
a big deal or how did it affect you
being you know in terms of where to the
studios that people you know deal with
you differently yeah I didn't notice
anything
I don't like it what I was naive maybe
people did react differently
I remember the first time
gravity chika-san there was a little big
group than everyone and I still remember
everyone's faces behind the glass in the
studio there was a real mayor AgrAbility
who's also one of the people who had a
big influence and that early days we'll
keep talking Iran and the guys at mr.
Dior like color and Muslims out there
and sir she was there and they were what
kind of and like looking really nah but
I didn't I that was my first experience
in studios I assumed that you know
that's how it worked but then when you
got out of the studio Merrick they were
like waiting for taxi and I said do you
know this is historical he said do you
know what this day is a historical day
and I was like and then he explained
because he was back then I think it was
doing his master's in musicology or
something so he you know he looked at
things a little bit differently I don't
if it was afterwards maybe it was a
little bit later but you know he had I
thinking he was looking at things in
that way I didn't it took me a long time
to look at things our own kind of just
being in them and he will he kind of was
saying that you know that's an important
step mm-hmm but I didn't saw a lot of
things I wouldn't notice I would just do
them because I was also even before
starting rapping I was doing graffiti
and that was also a thing that I didn't
even think that I'm doing something that
weird but later on people would tell me
oh no I guess I don't know that's crazy
what about the response and feedback
you'd get online huzzah yeah so that's a
hard thing because in the early days
also we didn't have big big groups
following us and I think everyone was
kind of in it and there were a lot of
girls also who followed and it was I
think mostly car encouraging
environments I didn't see anything weird
from anyone I remember though there was
also this thing people a lot there was
other groups there were different groups
and they would kind of make these diss
tracks this is a little different world
that I wasn't part of but you know they
they would make songs and maybe target
me and the way they would they would
insult everyone but the way David
insulted me would be the way you would
insult a woman you know the way you
would shame a woman which you know that
thought my son got kind of you know
pointing out so the sexism in there
could be kind of seen so that's a
another interesting point that I won't
make right now and it's probably gonna
be a bit news to a lot of you but you
know I didn't grow up listening to music
live the way we listen to music and
loved music and the way I loved hip-hop
to these tapes copied maybe 10 times
it's sit in a bedroom and in the
headphones really crappy quality and I
loved it I loved it it was my whole
world
that's how I loved music and still to
this day when I make music I make it for
people who listen to it and their
bedrooms and headphones I do and it's
one of those things and you know the
eventually obviously I realized oh I
guess we can't have a live performance
but I that was never when I started it
wasn't even in my mind it wasn't my
writer it wasn't in anyone's writer and
and I really interesting tidbit the
first rap performance I guess that
happened in Iran was in Turkish I have
HD it was a conference you know you know
you know what was the conference about
the inside effects or the negative sides
of smoking or something like that I
guess and um and a solution I kept like
guys they made the song about no cigar
not cash
I don't remember exactly what's in it
and I remember this conversation between
us that we're like kind of just before
it before done before the whole thing
happened it was a big deal but we were
kind of talking
should I go in the / - I kind of did the
back you know can do the faces it was so
many people on the stage and they were
all like saying cigar okay I was like I
could go to too but I'm like no my dad
don't kill me
that was the only thing on my mind I
didn't even think you know what the
government is gonna stop me that wasn't
even on the radar I just thought oh my
bad 19:19 yeah I wasn't that that young
but I was especially I was a little bit
of a shelter - yeah but at this point
and my dad and my family have it all
work that was also interesting because I
said okay I'm gonna stop making it up
and I had to tell them because every
time I met that I had to tell them where
I'm going and I'm 18 and my dad was like
okay so very going the studio where is
this who are you going with and I had to
introduce him to hitch gas and storage
and like he had to talk to him zero-hour
and like like okay and so douche
couldn't be really good in front of
parents okay look
definitely he was like okay but this guy
can go anywhere is fine my dad was
completely fine with it that how I
worked out but the earth performing
wasn't a my Raider and even after I left
Iran to pursue my education in Japan I
considered that oh maybe I can be more
performative now but I there was another
problem than the language because I'm in
new environments people don't know what
I'm saying I'm not gonna do Persian if
I'm in there so I started making video
arts and I got into the art world
basically and kind of since then I've
been going back and forth like I devote
a year for art and then I do an album
and then go back and do an art residency
somewhere and a little bit more video so
it's been like that it's still not much
on my radar I perform every now and then
like the
but did you ever engage in any I would
go but I was not big in battles I would
provide my Lords so I would think about
them and back then my early teen years I
was really into you know philosophy I
was reading eh-eh and you know he's like
it's like I would write a lot of heavy
philosophical stuff so I wasn't into you
know just saying these really
superficial and just you know that's how
and that's a whole other different
talent that you can have and people who
did them I thought they were great but I
I wasn't into it because I I wanted
everything that came out of my mind to
have meaning and because I come for also
and I thought about it later that why is
it that way because I come from this my
family you know my mom's a writer and my
dad's a journalist so I come from this
tradition of writing and boards meant
something and I don't come from is it
musical family it's really we're about
the writing and I cared about that a lot
I think I gave a lot of happiness to my
writing from the early days I want to
open it up to the to the audience if I
may just ask one more question
you've been very sort of cautious and
aware of being politicized and this has
gone back for a long time could you talk
a little bit about that you you have
also creative tracks that are political
you know a Shona Master Shake them s-so
which show off muscle shame my solution
no Matthew and you know I'm following
the 2009 the Green uprising so you've
also created political tracks but your
awareness or consciousness that being
politicized applies both sort of to the
approach of sort of Western media toward
you as a female rapper from Iran and
you've really tried to sort of keep a
very independent
and at times it's men sort of saying no
to you know MTV's sort of serious which
is on YouTube and a lot of people watch
which you know you've managed to say no
like I'm not I'm not going to be framed
like that can you talk a little bit
about where that comes from is that is
that where did where does that awareness
come from and how has it been
has it been sort of difficult
cultivating that sort of balance um you
know I talked about how I listen to him
in the early American hip hop that I was
listening was conscious of how I was
listening to people like immortal
technique and then prayers and yes and
Paris is when he could you had all been
changed my life so there's oldest from
the early days I had this thing and when
I was you know when I got into hip-hop
I wasn't I already had that you know
kind of fight the system by the
mainstream I wasn't even necessarily
thinking of Iranian government I was
thinking more global just scale like you
know oh the you know mainstream media
MTV is you know destroying us and then
you know entertainment industry is this
like I kind of had that outlook in a
very strict way you know cut teenage
baby I know change now but I think that
kind of kept me really skeptical and
cynical about Western media and actually
fires on it right here we just were
talking about cuz we were she was there
during internet galactic music festival
about ten years ago that happened
Amsterdam that was the first music
festival for everything either down
music and I kind of had a fight with
this BBC reporter because he was had a
similar approach when it to like kind of
sense I shall live since then since I
shouldn't know lies things so yeah it's
even then I was like really apprehensive
too because I knew that and also because
my father was a journalist I knew how
journalism works I knew how stories are
made and I didn't want to be used I
think and that is an every level of my
life I just didn't want to be Hughes I
didn't want to be used by media I didn't
want to be used by producers but
you know this wrapper or that wrapper
right kept that as your SATs kind of
wanted to be independent from any of
those side stories so it's kind of kept
my head down and did you know what I
wanted to do well I'm currently I love
last year I moved to from Japan I moved
to Seattle my husband and we are I'm
currently working with a nonprofit
basically in Japan I started going to
nonprofit route and like um kind of
committing myself to certain causes that
I liked and this specific nonprofit that
I'm working now with Jack Straw
organization does basically sound
projects for the community and a lot of
oral history education for children
based on sound based projects could be
poetry it could be music could be
podcasts and it's great and so I'm doing
sound engineering and videography which
is my was my day job in Japan but now
music sound and video came all together
and I can work in there and I really
want to expand how we do things like we
write proposals and get grants for
different projects and everything and I
have big projects in my mind we're
already talking about them and that's
one thing for my you know the the job my
job but also if you wanna when it comes
to hip-hop and you know my relationship
or on which I want to keep as long as I
can I'm in talks not with two girls who
are rapping in Iran and I want to be a
producer for them because I've been
producing for a while now and we
have female producers in Iran I I want
to basically produce for these girls and
kind of be a mentor and help them do
things inside Iran because girl like we
don't have a clear producer so they work
with male producers and I know from my
early days how it can limit your
creativity a lot if you're working with
someone who even slightly their vision
might be different from you
and I want them to have full freedom so
I want to offer that to girls with my
you found equipment that I have like
because I work at a studio and I have
some means to achieve that so that's
what I want to keep doing hopefully and
also keep making albums
I like making albums in Farsi and each
other
I made recently I made them make them
concept albums and they kind of here to
like a certain era of my life or
something I tell a story through the
whole album and I want to keep doing
that too next stage of my life I don't
know it could be having kids or whatever
whatever that entails yeah thank you
hi thank you for everything I actually
have a question in regards to production
because you you just talked about it and
I was wondering what is your production
process what kind of equipment you have
and how much you like music you record
how much of it is electronic and what
kind of programs like all all the back
backbone that nobody wants to talk about
yeah
yeah definitely I actually talked about
it I really like talking about online
too if you follow me because I know that
especially in Iran because people girls
don't really have a role model for
production they don't even know that
they can actually go out and produce and
it's not that hard and you really don't
need a lot of equipment for it and you
know I said up when I first had my home
studio it wasn't Iran and I really had
just saved up a little bit and started
really basic but yeah I mean I have a
sound card and I have a MIDI controller
I have some percussions that I really
like collecting percussion so I can get
different sounds I record Julie I use
when I'm programming the beats for
percussion section I would record some
life sounds and layered them with the
programs like VST is an audio units I
work with logic yeah but at the studio
at Jack's organization we use Pro Tools
so I've worked with both of them but at
home but I'm most comfortable with is
Logic Pro SOI with percussions usually I
record live but instruments if I find
sound like I get in if I meet a musician
that play something all right
I would be like let's record something
and I would record something for them
and then you know try to use that as
sample and use it for my beat it's nice
because I play keyboard
I'm not an instrumentalist though so I
like you know I mean if I find someone
that plays in this room really well I
try to take advantage of it and record
so I have a big archive of different
sounds that I recorded over the years
and I use them but they are most
comfortable just behind a computer and
doing the digital production
sorry thank you so many questions for
you trying to decide where you start but
I want to go back to my point about
media representation that many brought
up I'm interested in your thoughts not
only on the way that Iranian rapid is
portrayed in the media but the way that
Iranian rappers themselves interact with
the meat the Western media let's say and
so I'm interested to know if you feel
like this has also had an effect on how
the rap has Iranian rap has been
perceived in the international community
and I think it's inevitably that happens
I think each person have their own story
so we had musicians rappers that you
know they left Iran and then they wanted
to I don't maybe they had really extreme
experiences so they really wanted to say
extreme things about what happened back
in Iran I don't know I can't speak for
other people
everyone's experiences their own I don't
experience anything extreme so I have my
own story and that's what I tell so I'm
sure that but it's true that the
journalism journalists when they want to
make a story they go after people who
would have extreme examples they
wouldn't like if generalist they come
talk to me they're not gonna get
anything too sensational but said some
people will give them that kind of
information and but just I think it
wasn't your presentation right like the
if the story doesn't fit a certain
narrative it's not interesting to
Western audience so that's why the
journalists go after dad like if they if
the journalist comes and asking me if
why did you go to Japan and they want to
hear that oh I left because of green
woman then you were so impressed and
just like Swiss ah they're gonna love it
but if I tell them like a scholarship
from Japan and I'm gonna to do my
masters so I went that's not interesting
at all but that's the real story my
husband just came well I think the
impression we have is rap is the music
hip-hop is more of a subculture and you
know it's also included within itself
other elements of a pop culture like
graffiti which I also did and
breakdancing DJing so hip hop when you
say pop music people understand what it
means but it also has you know if you're
talking about a more general sense and
you say hip-hop culture people also know
what what do you mean um so yeah we have
that I think this was one of those early
discussions that we were having what is
hip hop I just wrap and you were right
about those but well yeah we would say
okay I hip hop is the culture you have
spoken word artists
we have similar things in Iran we've had
I think it's not name spoken word but we
had the clammy honey and we have this
tradition of you know oral storytelling
since the long long time ago so it's not
necessarily spoken word as in like slam
poetry or anything like that but I'm
sure we have now you know people who
specifically named at that but if you if
you say spoken word I guess it depends
on what you mean but I think yeah but it
can be Puritan you can't just perform it
but it can be something that they wrote
before it doesn't have to be improvised
with spoken word so it's similar to and
you know in Iran you have um yeah I
think we have some things like similar
to spoken word but I don't know of any
specific moment that is spoken word as
in the American like imported from
America culture that you were referring
to so in your late teens and early 20s
being part of that culture in Iran what
did it mean who else was part of it you
know what was it was there any sort of
political directionality no was it just
sort of a way of being young in the
world they were mixing to sort of other
you know global this global culture of
hip-hop or did you have any awareness of
any of that can you just speak a little
bit about what it meant to be part of
that I think a lot of it was like
teenage rebellion it was it just was
good to like I was writing graffiti and
there was this graffiti scene the first
one of the forefathers of graffiti eat
alone Tehran in Tehran he he was my
mentor and he'd created beautiful pieces
and some of his pieces were political my
pieces weren't
I just liked making this nicely shaped
phones with my name I wrote some a and
the balls and I actually usually ask for
permission like at my school University
at the back there was this carwash and I
asked them can I paint over your wall
and they said okay it's already right
dirty anyway it's not gonna make a
difference you know
so my girlfiend writing was that kind of
experience um but I think you know
people people like me or early Tina's
like other people who did graffiti like
Kavon came on and a few others I think
also it was just you know that energy
that you had as a young person and you
wanted to express it and kind of feel a
little bit you know in the edge and kind
of feeling like you were doing something
that's different from the rest of the
society but taka alone who was kind of
older than us he did have those ago
pieces so I think there were different
people differently and then there was
this guys that it's you know
skateboarding and Parker more ballet and
they also considered themselves as as
part of you know hip-hop culture and I
think they weren't really that political
either they were just kind of being gone
and edgy how did this um as far as you
were part of it how did this seem come
together was it can you talk a little
bit about its publicness or whether of
being oftentimes in private spaces how
that affected the what you know the
constitutionality of this disprove and
the scene I think in the early days we
didn't really think of it as a scene it
became a scene afterwards looking back
so I don't know if it actually was a
scene or what that means I think we just
came together people who had similar
interests kind of support each other and
hung out together did things we didn't
necessarily think over creating at
moments or over influencing the society
we weren't releasing
that what everyone generalize was I'm
just gonna speak for myself but I think
that's how others so - but you know we
were putting things out there so when I
made a graffiti I put the you know I
took a picture and put it online and I
made a song I put it online so that they
vents and became their own thing it I
didn't necessarily did all of these to
create a moment and I don't think I
don't know if the other guys were you
know I borrowed it and they did it
intentionally but I doubt it so he was
really just being together having that
common interests and the sense of
community was big a lot of it was online
but then we got to hang out in parts
mostly there were few actually quite a
few there was one of the first women
that I have which Matt's is one of my
best friends currently Morales she was
she wanted to meet up with me and beat
me up
so that was you know the we were that
young that's how it was and then we met
up and then we talked and she's like oh
you're so different
I thought and yeah there were there
there were girls in the world like just
young and trying to be different and
express ourselves the way they are the
way we felt different we wanted to
express it and feel like we are
different
yes it's really changed things are very
different now that early sense of
community doesn't exist anymore because
it blew and it turned into something
else it mutated it became a scene and
then later it was a moment then it was
the whole thing and there's not the
third generation of musicians they're
amazing graffiti artists out there so
yeah it's it's different now definitely
and that sense of community doesn't
exist much because a lot of competition
has started we didn't really compete
that we were all kind of all together
helping each other but now there's all
these different people and it's
understandable because the competition
happens naturally because you want to
put your song out there and you want it
to be heard and you wanna try to be
different and so you you know that that
naturally happens that you discomfort
illness but it also creates the sense
and people who want to start that you
know they're not gonna make it so they
give up so I meet a lot of girls like
that so there are many girls but there a
lot of girls who want to do it and they
email me and I try to guide them but
it's not like the other days that you
could just do it and not even think that
you just automatically had audience
everyone was each other's audience it's
not like that anymore because there are
millions of listeners and it's there are
thousands of singers and it's hard to
certainly separate yourself and rice we
can only take a few more questions and I
wanted to go to the to the person back
and you have the microphone already or
okay yes so I have an American question
which is if you could collaborate with
any American female hip-hop artist who
would it be and why good question
[Music]
one so I listen to a lot of like the
hip-hop that I listen is mostly from 90s
America so I really liked early a female
MCS like salt-n-pepa you know I don't
know much about what's happening
currently so you know I love Lauren Hill
if I can collaborate it was thoroughly
my dream but I think anyone would be
great like people who share the same
similar if I could find someone and meet
someone with same shirts like a similar
values and similar worldview
I would love to collaborate but yeah
Lauren Hill nice she was yeah just great
but she won't collaborate I don't think
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so early days I did I did rappin
cause I D I have a song about naft but
anyway that was one of the songs that I
successfully erased left Internet hi it
wasn't really cool here and it was a
collaboration with a Turkish rapper and
we were just so off like we're talking
about different things and I was still
trying to understand Turkish and how it
works like structurally
for rapping and just didn't work out but
anyway yeah I did try but ah sorry and
Japanese I never got my Japanese level
then we got to a level where I can
comfortably write what I actually want
to say so I never got there but
didn't collaborate with the Japanese
rapper hip-hop artist machine go to and
that we do one sentence in Japanese
which is a sentence from one of my
favorite Japanese poets my so by show
Kimmy taught me me sheet it's a video so
be cutter so yeah like every day is a
journey and the journey itself is home
that's the meaning of the that verse so
I used that I said only that and English
myelitis although might have some
English versus naturally and I think you
know I finish this album and my albums
are always had this latency they had
about what happened to even before like
the last three three years or four years
or something so this album that I
released in August now Michelle guy is
basically covered in my life in Japan
and I'm making the third and last music
video for it currently there are two
music videos out there already so if you
watch them one of them is actually made
by tan ha or alone it was the you know
one of the pioneers of street art in
Iran so it's really great stop-motion
music video please watch it the I'm
making the third music video and nothing
gonna be done with us album and then I'm
gonna look and see what I want to do and
I think there's a good chance that I'm
gonna do something heavily English just
naturally because of I'm living here and
I absorbing a lot downloading a lot of
things currently just you know into my
world so that's I think actually gonna
happen but yeah I already bits English
stuff and my new album
well I did English and Farsi my song and
I did with the Japanese I did that one
sentence with Farsi Japanese and then
she goes that's English but yeah
but I was on your first together I
didn't it's a good idea I want to do
something else re cuz my ah sorry it's
not that great it's good but you know my
dad is from Mumia so every time we went
there and I'm gonna I'm gonna like talk
to everyone I always was a little bit
self-conscious because I do have an
accent in outsid so I don't know if I
can you know use it in the best way I
want to do because it's a part of my
heritage and I how's that I think eyes
area is really beautiful language so
I'll definitely want to do that that's
that's well with Iran it's complicated
because when I left then I went to Japan
I go scholarship you know I did and the
the plan was I'm gonna get my masters
and go back and teach and actually my
professor at school kind of pushed me to
get the scholarship and she was like
well you're gonna come back and teach
and she loved me because I basically
translated a book in her name that was
published but that's academia Iran but
so I went there but then things didn't
you know went according to plan so you
know I got married and worked and like
stayed and worked in Japan and just and
I kept thinking okay I guess it's you
know I'm out of Iran now like how why
thought about it like why continue
making music in Farsi and well the
answer is worse okay I'm gonna do I'm
going into the art world and express
tell my story as in the formal video and
sound or
and stop making it but then I have a
connection in the form of my audience
that because I have a fan base there
it's not big but they're really devoted
and they ask for things and they're
really insistent and I feel a
responsibility like I released an album
four months ago and people already are
like why aren't you giving any new songs
like I released an album did you know I
was like yeah that was four months ago
people demand things and I feel
responsibility and I feel it it really
excites me their excitement excites me
and then I wanted some more stories in
Farsi and it's kind of became this thing
so I'm connected through them to Iran
but the way I tell stories changed now
they become a lot more personal and a
lot more global like this album like the
the songs you watched maybe you looked
at it from Iranian government
oppressions but it wasn't that it's my
experiences in Japan and generally about
part patriarchal societies and can
confirm to anywhere like it can be
America the stories that I told so you
know it becomes I don't I don't I can't
talk for you know what's life like in
Iran anymore
when I wasn't in Iran I made songs about
social political situations but I don't
anymore because I don't have the similar
sense that I did when I was in there I
can read news I can listen to people but
I don't I can't talk candidly about it
so I just talk about my own experiences
that's right in Iran - I talked of my
own experiences so and hopefully they'll
keep listening I know I said that was
the last question I wonder if anybody
else has a question because if I have
one last
don't ask you you have one girlfriend
actually we're recording we'd like to
put this on youtube so if you don't mind
just waiting for the light
so I had a question because you were so
close and kind of insider to what was
happening in the kind of hip-hop scene
or community that was taking place
I'm just very curious about but were
there people from different parts of
this big wood neighborhood are we
talking about everyone acting is I'm all
bought or it was a collection of these
people from different neighborhoods have
different cinema are there people yeah
definitely us it's actually really
interesting because um I think because
we all kind of met on the internet it
was fairly diverse like the backgrounds
of different people I come from you know
middle-class family we weren't that
regim different like my father was a
journalist working for the government
and my mom was a writer didn't even earn
money so the there were people who were
a little more affluent you know but
Ashanti and there were people who were
actually you know lived in a less
fortunate parts of Tehran like you know
Jim sherry there were all parts but they
the commonality was like we have we live
in this society and we're not conforming
in different ways my thing was you know
I want to you know people are blind and
I want to tell this story is like you
know don't you know don't swim against
mainstream you know things like that
like I don't know teenage stuff Suroosh
was like really into each gas was really
into kind of pushing this really sweet
kind of narrative and some of these were
acts but you know there were really well
done acts and then there were people who
were actually you know romantic
and they would talk about not having
money and have what is life you know
like that like it is lucky she was like
that so yeah I think we were from all
over but Vanek was one of the places
that we would meet up because it was
really a central and ahead of an act it
had like a park over there and we would
meet there a lot it was other Park Park
everybody that night mentioned was in
shock at our I didn't like much going
there but that was like a more affluent
part of city and I didn't feel like I
belong yeah but I think it was fairly
diverse relatively and it's even more
diverse now you can see all kinds of
people like religious non-religious
affluence more madam yeah so perhaps as
a closing question if I may since we've
been talking about sort of you know the
government regulating you know not you
know restricting or banning the solo
female voice and just generally we've
talked about the government and its
regulations you obviously released all
your tracks and you're rapping in you
know in part singing solo have you had
any interactions with government
regulatory bodies and is that something
that you can talk about so this is
something I don't like talking about one
of the furnaces for us when I'm gonna is
um a lot of people use this kind of
interactions and exaggerate them too cuz
you know Western audience likes it and I
just didn't want it to be a part of my
narrative like I thought it will
distract from what I'm trying to do but
if it's interesting for you guys as you
know Academy and historians I did have
interactions with them and I can tell
you my interactions from what I
understood that Iranian until you
agency is really incompetent they're
really not that scary or they're not
even that good at what they do
so I really didn't think it didn't scary
at me as much I think other people have
different I'd see her different things
my experience was these guys don't know
what they're doing
did those interactions ever change the
course of what you were making
no but part of it was I was lucky enough
to kind of I left kind of after that
after initial interactions and when I
returned for winter holidays
I had another interaction and that was a
little bit scary but didn't change but
then I left and then I think here so it
didn't affect what I did as far as I
know but who knows like I didn't have
any conscious effect anyway but I think
I've been always self censoring as Paula
was saying like there was always a sense
of self-preservation but not necessarily
just from the Iranian government's but
from family friends like you know
society probably even more from society
then the government's I lived in
boundaries' Valley for a year because I
had this notion that all Tehran is
making me depressed I'm gonna go live in
the small city and be happy so I've
worked in abandoned so there was a small
port port city and castle near Caspian
Sea for a year after I graduated from
school and that was a burst here with my
life because it's a small city and my
landlord like live right upstairs and
and I've worked and this and I worked at
the
Natalia's odd which is this economically
free zone so there are lots of factories
there I've often a clothing factory as a
designer and in the factory is just
gossip gossip everyone knows each other
and people constantly talking about
about each other and it was so
oppressive I actually felt a press in
there from people and there noisiness in
Tehran yes you have you had cash -
adorable I didn't feel as a pastor at
least you know you have that sense of
freedom that the big city provides which
people you know don't care about each
other because everyone has so much to
worry about small cities they don't so I
don't know where I have to get here but
society yes I think society I think him
the society the you know censorship from
society is a lot bigger factor I didn't
necessarily count government as a thing
but I also had a lot of self-confidence
in the way I was underground I thought I
hid my name very well and I didn't even
I didn't put out pictures that much I
still don't because I don't like it
and the I also I really songs that maybe
politically were too sensitive I don't
listen maybe a bit a different name
which saw me is already different name
but I haven't really summer been evident
more differently so I would go even like
really more cuz like there's always a
way I mean I put things out there and I
don't think the restrictions necessarily
made me censor myself too much because
there's always a way to find go there
cracks and you can flow through great
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]